c'est ça aussi bonjour merci être en
direct avec nous sur rt france
alors peut-on confirmé que bozizé
désormais le chef de la coalition des
rebelles c'est juste une clarification
que nous savions déjà puisque il faisait
pas de tout hacker que ce soit que
bozizé était le chef de la cpc cette
fois ci s'est formé le mahdi est
confirmée est là certes est donc le chef
de la rébellion et c'est une information
qui nous désole moiteur qui sont engagés
pour la paix alors la question qui avait
pris la tête de la rébellion pour
renverser le président toi d'erreur il
ya quatre 4 mois était en recul
pensez-vous que la direction officielle
de bousiller leur donnera plus de poids
alors vous savez pour détruire c'est
toujours facile pour conçu c'est
difficile je disais que nous regrettons
cette décision du président bozizé
parce qu'aujourd'hui la cpc et c'est
donc de remettre en cause les acquis
démocratiques encore fragile de la
république centrafricaine je ne pense
pas qu'aujourd'hui qu'ils aient les
moyens nécessaires mais c'est des gens
qui sont habitués à la rébellion qui
sont engagés dans le temps long et le
temps l'on joue un peu à leur faveur
mais il n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui nous
pouvons dire que l'état simplifie caire
a continué à pacifier son territoire il
ya beaucoup de campagnes sont terminées
pour donc à faire en sorte que le
territoire soit libéré et ce que nous
pouvons espérer c'est que l'ensemble des
partenaires de l'armée centrafricaine
les pays limitrophes notamment puissent
l'accompagner dans cet effort de
pacification durable et que monsieur vos
idées plus y revenir à la raison
combattre le présent 3 dira avec les
âmes démocratique et non avec des armes
militaires parce que la centrafique
notre pas continuer avec des coups
d'état ou pouvoir fonctionner est
vraiment nous récompense était arrivé
depuis 2013 l'ex chef de l'état tente de
revenir au pouvoir par tous les moyens
comment analysez vous cette nouvelle
stratégie d'alliance alors je pense que
celle-là petit de pouvoir effectivement
le président bozizé envie de revenus
tout en pouvoir ce qui est légitime
on peut pas refuser un acteur
centrafricain de vouloir diriger son
pays
ce qui est regrettable c'est de choix
des armes qui sont présents et je pense
aujourd'hui que le présent bozizé a
devant l'histoire et que le pays
d'artois dirhams
s'il ya des gens qui ne l'apprécient pas
ils sont obligés de reconnaître que il
en train de changer le pays par des
voies démocratiques et c'est sur ce
terrain que c'est d'après cette
politique doit le combattre et donc nous
espérons que cette dynamique du prénom
bozize elle n'ira pas l'un c'est un
espoir que nous asseoir à avoir pour la
centrafique passé ottoman le payer cela
dans un cycle infernal du conflit armé
est aujourd'hui en tout cas et non pas
en quoi la puissance nécessaire ils sont
reclus et à différents endroits avec
l'intention de revenir certainement et
c'est pourquoi nous pensons
qu'aujourd'hui où la foi de défense et
de sécurité centrafricain d'ordre est
assez vigilante pour faire en sorte que
les victoires qu'elle commence à voir le
soit pas de victoire pour qu'ils voient
eux vont dormir sur leurs lauriers parce
que dès lors que le présent vous existez
vraiment de prendre la tête de la
rébellion
c'est qu'il est déterminé et quand il
est déterminé cela veut dire que c'est
pas une bonne nouvelle pour la
tranquillité des personnes mais nous
espérons que tout ce qui est en cours
aujourd'hui va faire en sorte que la
paix sera dur à france en profiter que
la démocratie sera le seul à seul
vainqueur
merci beaucoup quel signe aussi d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je vous rappelle
que vous êtes directeur de l'institut
international ad gestion des conflits